Hello. Welcome.
It's March 27th, 2026.
We are live in the Active Inference
Institute's first quarterly round table
for the year.
This is Daniel, and I'm with Alexandra
and Oliana. So, Oliana,
want to say hello and then Alexandra.
Hello to everyone. Welcome in.
Okay.
And
Hi, my name is Alexandra. I'm
the officer or the other officer for the
Active Inference Institute, and I'm
happy to be here.
Okay.
Some short links and
directions, ways to get involved.
This is a first quarterly round table.
We've been doing these quarterly since
2021.
And there will be some overview slides,
new fresh takes on the new and the old
ways.
Go over some institute updates,
project scale updates, and then look at
any questions that are in the live chat.
Starting with the annual rhythm, we're
finishing out now the quarter one,
which had a lot of onboardings, and
we're heading into second quarter.
July will be summer break.
Continue on through the Applied Active
Inference Symposium in November,
and then have offboardings.
And
on the above dash line part
are some of the joint attentions that
will be happening around the institute
and in in the ecosystem,
starting with onboarding,
going in the coming weeks to the to the
first textbook group around the new
fundamentals of active inference book,
staying updated with core theory
development,
towards the middle of the end of the
year, developing different domain
applications,
upskilling on different frameworks,
looking at how they version, leading up
to the symposium in November, and
highlighting industry and individuals,
people working on different problems,
different ways, and then learning.
And then on the bottom are just some of
the ways to start with connecting,
collaborating, looking at what's out
there already, adding in pieces that
you're working on yourself,
different programs like internship,
research fellows, all these other
projects that are happening on their own
timescales. So,
anything to add on that?
Okay. And here's some new
uh layouts, things that we've been
exploring just to expose a little bit
from the board of directors with Oliana
and
others.
Um
It's a it's a a bit hasty in its
composition, but
on the top are cognitive things
interacting with worlds.
And that can be approached from sort of
first principles.
It can be approached from the
interactive
perspective, and looking at sort of the
philosophy of interactions and their
material basis.
It can be approached from this agent
niche partition into two or into four.
We've seen it relate to the quantum
reference frames
and measurement at different scales.
And
repeated
preparation and measurements across
interfaces.
So, that's that sort of
first principles of interaction
that we return to, whether we're
thinking about cognitive things, mental
spaces,
abstract spaces
through worlds.
And then here are some of the more
cognitive things,
like ideas and shared attention,
attractors, like mission, vision,
values, things that we've been exploring
in the board, and our pillars and our
focus at the institute, which are rigor,
accessibility, and applicability.
And then how that sort of
is making its way into what that looks
like to be changing our morphology, our
actions, our niche, and some early
thinking around different ways to stage
projects to respect that pathway and
different dwelling points and different
entry points for projects that vary in
so many different ways.
Want to add anything on this last of two
overview slides?
Okay.
Going into a couple institute programs
and updates.
Research fellows, we have eight research
fellows at the beginning of the year and
have just approved and onboarded three
more, who are Mal Abrason,
Alexander Hemming, and Jay Cooper.
Just over the last few days.
These research fellows are
working on a variety of projects. We'll
share more in detail over the coming
year.
For now, exciting to see these three
researchers, and we'll share more in the
coming months.
Want to add anything?
Um yeah.
Uh
just to consider applying to be a
research fellow,
um
you know, it really does take all kinds,
and um we want to support a diverse
uh ecosystem of research fellows in
active inference and the various
projects that people undertake.
Partnerships update. We have two current
partners, First Principles First and
Newman Games,
both of who have
gotten involved with symposium and other
activities over the years.
And these partnerships are something
we're developing some
different lanes around, and also we'll
share more and co-evolve that with those
who are interested in being
organizations that are looking to make
some type of engagements with structure,
expectations,
and work in a way that's aligned among
organizations, and supports what we do
through technical collaboration,
sponsorship, and other ways to support.
So,
something we'll share more about in the
coming months,
and or reach out if that's interesting.
We have, I think, 30-few
people
on the scientific advisory board for
this year,
and have gotten off to a very
interesting start. So, their names are
all written here. Many first-timers, as
well as those who have been on for
several years.
Currently, the focus areas are
serving as reviewers and advisors around
the research fellows program in their
applications and also in their ongoing
reviews.
Exploring survey data and ways to sense
make with community feedback.
For example, using the registration
information from the last year's
symposium, looking at the questions like
related to what people are working on,
what they find useful.
Engaging in mentorship with interns as
well as well as those who are not in an
internship.
Helping give insight and advocate for
partnerships
and represent partnerships.
Engaging in individual
project facilitation, and just being
involved with projects more generally.
Helping
co-organize or present or otherwise
support the symposium.
And giving insight to the board, and
coming up with different feedback around
the mission and vision work from the
beginning of this year.
So, thank you to the SAB for their
volunteer
work.
Anything to add?
Okay.
Here is our officers, Alexandra and I
here, and our 2026 board of directors
shown here,
and
more to come. Thank you to all of the
board for their work. It was a very
active quarter.
And this is our donation link if you
want to support the institute through
donation or get in touch of some other
way to help or engage.
Okay.
Anything
before going to projects?
Okay. Going into different projects that
are ongoing and upcoming.
So, one of the highlights of this
quarter in the active inference
ecosystem
is the publication of this new textbook
by Sanjeev Namjoshi
Fundamentals of Active Inference:
Principles, Algorithms, and Applications
of the Free Energy Principle for
Engineers.
And
having completed about nine
cohorts going through the 2022
Parr, Pezzulo, and Friston textbook
it came at a a perfect time
in many ways
and we will be beginning the first
cohort of the Fundamentals textbook
group in about
2 to 3 weeks.
You can go to this textbook group link
to register
or get in touch.
Thanks to Andrew Pichaya and Fraser
Patterson, who'll be facilitating a
meeting per week and contributing their
expertise, both of whom who have helped
in these ways before.
And also
here's from the acknowledgement section
of the book
which acknowledges the institute. So,
those who are listed here and others who
joined those meetings
that was a really uh great way
to engage with Sanjeev
in the lead up to this book and in the
versioning and so, cool to see how that
sort of volunteer contribution can be
recognized and and also on individuals
learning um paths, which is
going to get kind of kicked into a
different gear with how this book is
structured and conveyed.
And I think the uh relatively
high level of engagements
around this book
is going to bode well
for a very epistemic and pragmatic 2026.
>> [sighs]
>> The AI Capabilities and Alignment
Project AICACP
is a
funded project
and Adam Safron et al. continue some
very interesting work with the journal
articles and other convenings around
this topic
and we will update more
later this year on the AICACP.
The Theoretical Neurobiology Group TNB
Group
which uh in their across their objective
has been fostering interdisciplinary
research and collaboration for decades.
Our mission is to advance the
understanding and application of active
inference, a theoretical framework
developed by Professor Karl Friston. And
this is a research, presentation, and
discussion group
with most of their videos available on
YouTube. However, also the real life
meetings with Karl Friston et al.
are available to join into and be a part
of. So
whether you want to catch up on these
roughly weekly
interesting long-form
cutting-edge research presentations and
discussions
or you want to kind of break the fourth
wall and be on the other side then this
is an awesome way to do that with these
researchers.
In the first quarter, we had several
guest streams. We had
Chris Fields and James Leyshon present
on their quantum information systems
book.
Bobby Azarian
gave a presentation on the strange loop.
And yesterday
uh Bojan Milankovic discussing the
artificial consciousness.
Several model streams.
Patrick Kenny presented on active
inference in discrete state spaces.
Kendrick Nelson on learning extreme
models with a coupled free energy.
And Can Demir on distributional active
inference.
I did several streams presenting on the
courses
repo
which generates material and will be a
later slide as a sort of starting point
for different kinds of lengths and
focuses for
uh active inference educational
materials
and a template approach.
All of our videos are available
and also over this past
quarter
um if if you want to
get involved with producing your own
series of active inference related
material
like Darius did with insights or others
have done at times
this would be a good year to do it.
On the tool development side
advances in code development have made
it
possible to revisit some of the projects
that we've often discussed and people
have raised as possible over the years
like having all the transcripts for the
over 700 videos on our YouTube channel
and engaging in
uh retrieval augmented generation
of those materials with the local LLM.
So, the journal utilities
uh repo
has those tools
to pull audio-visual transcripts and to
have a chat with local LLM.
And these are the kinds of things that
were exploring in these sort of widening
spirals and hopefully we'll be able to
start to provide some of these through
hosted interfaces
for different kinds of simulations and
knowledge resources.
On a sort of related vein
the courses repo developed over this
last quarter
makes
starting
point
modular course material that can be
targeted in terms of the length, like
the number of modules and sections per
module
the focus domain, the extent of math and
programming used, the target age, the
natural language
and uh a bunch of versions are generated
or if you get the idea, then you can
kind of take it from there.
And pops up published material,
different formats, PDF
markdown, audio
also has the ability to do a local
interface with offline learning
and also the kind of thing that
hopefully will be developed more this
year
and um useful for those who want to
engage with this kind of material.
One of the ongoing projects at the
institute has been the rxinfer.jl
learning group where Fraser Patterson
has been facilitating this group
um twice a week and uh
people have been joining.
Um
it's a very interesting framework and
the group has been doing awesome
methodical work in learning as well as
applying it and contributing to the
package.
Okay.
Leaving the institute projects section,
going to the ecosystem projects. So, all
the following updates are things that
basically we heard about through people
filling out the
measure.activeinference.institute
form.
So, if you ever have a sort of update
that you want to share whether it was a
paper that you came across or produced
yourself
this is
a form that will
allow us to bring visibility to that
work and and highlight what's happening
that's cool in the ecosystem.
Bert de Vries reports
he taught some lectures on active
inference at the machine learning summer
school in Melbourne.
The lecture materials are available.
And he has made a LinkedIn post about
it.
The call for submissions is open for the
7th International Workshop on Active
Inference, IY7.
The workshop will take place in the
Spanish National Research Council in
Madrid, Spain from 14th to 16th October
2026.
So this is
a highlight of the year for many.
Conor Hines announced the release of
pymdp 1.0.0.
It was at a hanging around there double
double-07 for a while.
And we will have an upcoming model
stream
on April 9th
for Conor and other developers to
present some of the updates and
examples.
So, that'll be big for Pi MDP fans
everywhere.
I published a paper, a template approach
to reproducible generative research, and
has a repo, and did a stream overviewing
it a little bit.
Fun way to make pretty customized
documents that have reproducible
scientific floats.
Okay.
Last part.
Uh just to put it a few ideas that we
worked up into slides that there there's
more happening and more was already
mentioned as well.
Different ways to just look towards the
coming year and also put out there
what what will make it epistemic and
pragmatic for you and what what other
paths can we explore?
So, first the Applied Active Inference
Symposium, we had the fifth one in
November of 2025
and soon we will be beginning the
organizing for the 2026 symposium.
Um
it takes many people to co-organize and
the the more the merrier and the better.
We have a template to organize it and
can pick up from where and how we did it
last year and do it more and differently
this year.
So, get in touch if you want to
co-organize or if you want to even
present or sponsor or engage in some
other way.
Go for it.
Um
yeah, just to reiterate uh
you know, it really does take all kinds
and um we're just looking for all the
different uh skills and contributions
that people are ready to make. Um
to help uh help us have an even better
symposium um this year. It gets a little
little better
a little more aesthetic every year um
and so it's a lot of fun to be in that
early ideating process um and just get
the ball rolling early in the year.
And the second one here is the help
desk.
So, the institute receives a variety of
inquiries
throughout the day.
Technical questions, searching for
community or mentors, interest in
internships
forwarded communications from other
researchers, broad metaphorical
illusions, news and other publications,
and more.
And so, one of our new initiatives is
the help desk
where we will respond to all requests in
a systematic and thorough manner.
So,
reassessing
and configuring and augmenting how we've
done this before for years
and using that intake opportunity to
update our offerings, our world model,
and also provide services directly for
the ecosystem.
So, here are two uh real photos
taken of what the help desk looks like.
All right.
That is it for
the updates.
Alexandra, Oliana, feel free to add
anything.
Just a thank you, Daniel for your really
excellent organization and presentation.
This is very comprehensive and it gives
us all a good um eagle's eye view of
what's going on with the institute.
Um
yeah, always fun to
have this retrospective uh several times
per year and um you know
gives you a little bit of that thrill of
making a committee presentation slides.
Um
and uh
yeah, trying to put together
because uh a lot of work and a lot of
thought has has been put into it in the
last 3 months and uh to best reflect
that with our slides and
images and graphics um is a lot of fun.
Um so, yeah. So, just uh
happy to give people a inside peek of
what happens at the institute.
Okay.
Hello Love Evolve. Hello Kenrick.
If anyone has a question, we'll just
wait 1 more minute. Otherwise, I'll flip
through the slides from the beginning
again.
Okay.
A
almost 26-minute update
appropriate for the 26th year.
All right.
Thank you.